le feu d'artifice c'est un peu la pierre
angulaire des bouquins de la baie et
l'édition 2019 ses 4500 départ
d'artifice soit plus de 320 kg de
matière active et même si cette année le
spectacle sera un peu plus court
son chef d'orchestre promet qu'il n'en
sera pas moins intense
pour sa huitième participation ils
cherchent encore à surprendre
on a toujours envie de faire mieux cette
année
c'est presque tous les artificiers qui
participent gracieusement d'événements
pour maintenir un certain niveau de
qualité
on va avoir des effets près des effets
premium des effets qui sont avec des
lotos des bombes cylindrique avec des
couleurs ultra vives du jamais vu un
budget plus restreint qu'en 2010 890
milles euros
les organisateurs comptent donc sur les
partenaires privés pour maintenir le
niveau de l'événement et pour les 350
ans de fort de france
de nombreuses animations sont prévues
avant le feu d'artifice et le concert à
partir de 16 heures le public est invité
à prendre possession du patrimoine
muséal et muséographique de
fort-de-france cathédrale musée
d'archéologie précolombienne
il y a également un rendez vous pour les
gourmands et les gourmets
chacun est invité à passer à table une
vingtaine de restaurants ont signé pour
l'édition 2019
côté musique une première scène avec dj
bayous et des dream doit attirer un
public plutôt jeune et puis en tête
d'affiche ce sont les trois ténors ralph
thamar hypo gertrude et tony chasseur
qui animeront la grande fête
dernière répétition pour eux ont choisi
lors des chansons et on peaufine des
derniers accords
on a un partage de la scène avec ralph
tony chasseur et moi-même et retracer
une période musicale hyper sympathique
et des duos des trios et puis de ce qui
a été fait pendant un certain nombre
d'années dé père est là aussi pour
partager des moments merveilleux comme
trois monuments de la musique
martiniquaise qui se produiront durant
plus de deux heures trente de concert
le spectacle promet d'être à la hauteur
des 350 ans de la ville de fort de
france
[Musique]